lenti marroni benvenuti a minori gli
estranei comunale oggi nuova challenge
slam quest'anno challenge stuber
particolare perché vi ricordate che ho
già fatto la challenge compro tutto
quello che riesci a sillabare l'accusa
sperling challandes in america questa
volta però la faremo con gli ingredienti
slime viene godette che se l'altro video
avesse raggiunte 15 mila mi piace
l'avremmo fatta nuovamente nvidia ha
raggiunto e 15 mila mi piace solo in un
giorno se siete fantastici quindi se
questo video raggiunge ai vecchi mila mi
piazzo devo fare una terza parte in cui
andremo a comprare le cose snidarli ero
nei commenti cosa potremmo mettere in
palio domandiamo comprare il cibo così
l'abbiamo tutto qui il mio nome vorrà
invitare a non avete visto la cia le
soppressione mente come funzionano e
gireremo la ruota qualsiasi numero ci
capita dovremmo comporre una parola
phone o quel numero di lettere in questo
caso dovranno essere ingredienti per lo
slime alla fine del video che avrà lo
slime più bello vincerà e dovrete
votarlo poi dal sondaggio è ovviamente
modo per berlina canta partecipato
marino sta dormendo stoffa avevano
grafiche st 7 toni poi pensa qualche
correntina e noi lavoriamo asmini anni
la mente fateci sapere se anche voi tre
cavi sono così scorrendo ripresa ogni 10
minuti
troppo per noi perché sono terribili
grandi gambe
vediamo che non esca anzi una tra poco
siete pronti come crediamo è tornato il
giro piano però ai trenta secondi per
trovare una parola con quattro lettere
line berlus live con il 5 aiuto non so
che cosa c'è niente con quattro lettere
soluzione l'olio con lei o olio contarsi
dai di aglio e al rende noto di non
voler essere
mancano le lettere tutto per 44 mentre
sta per partire una parola questo non
vuol dire niente
[Musica]
44 10 45 18
una cosa però non va bene adesso ma se
non mi capita dopo il meglio che la
metto subito a me farlo notare
allora cosa vito trovare le lettere tu
devi continuare a contare 8 non saranno
nove hanno tutti ingredienti buddismo
dal tibet o dici
l attimo valore che non me la faccia un
bel niente perché non ho neanche la
parola adesso però è meglio che lo metto
subito perché se poi magari mi capita la
colla e poi non mi capiterà attivatore
non potrò mai attivare allo slide quindi
sarà come fare lo slam al contrario cioè
iniziare dalla città tore e poi mettere
me non è giusto io non sono niente buffa
quindi vado ammette il mio attivatore
all'area mette la mia strutture per
lenti meno sono sicura che dopo il mio
tennis si attiverà 7 non capito 10 non
potrei aver tifare illuminato arrivare
ma neanche allora scusa ecco come
facciamo poi a finire che tu avrai la
minor attivato ammette il bicarbonato di
sodio ed ecco fatto però ai sette ora
aspetta
oddio come si fa a non lo so se sono
giuste le fossette forse l'ho trovato
esanime marrone non c'è la loro tesi che
gioca che abbiamo prendendo che abbiamo
d'arma remondina parlare no è la tesi
spiegare perché una scala del tempo
buffon 102
gestione 12345678 ma 7 123456 s.giovanni
vedere solo con i clip avevano fatto un
po al contrario a metà da meta al
portare allora faccio vedere che i
colori di glitter s ho scelto il celeste
il giallo e il blu e adesso li mettiamo
tutti insieme è invece il mio ci sono
l'associazione borletti bicarbonato
speriamo che mi capiti la colla
vediamo un po il tuo diventerò sono
bitter che era un bellissimo aspetto
aiuto io l'ho saputo mi fare tu esatto
infatti deve capitare il barone e anche
la colla ok anche amnesty che voi che mi
capiti dai col 6 danza cos'è pagine non
s
niente caffè lettere iscrivetevi
commenti cosa c'è così le tre minuti un
misero cosche cosa vediamo spero di non
sbagliarmi per totti ci aspetta allora
matera lingue delle stelle tester
novembre per una sterlina non sono mai
ve ne fate li difende nostro servizio al
thani dallo stesso farà le scelte sono
delle stelline gialle stupende ma la
prima di metterle il mio nonno slime
attira vitale vado andiamo di ruviano 5
o papà papà mi è venuta l'idea tra
l'altro fa è meglio che ti sbrighi
perché io ho iniziato a contare da
subito ad allora sono più cattivo che
faccia la misura f24
e lì era pronto a mangiatele colla
sicura le più belle folle almeno tre ci
stanno e allora siccome sono un po non
aprendo solo due tronconi al plurale
equa i tuoi obama mi ha fatto casino
allora va io il gol
roma sceglierei queste due qui argento è
come sappiamo che vogliono caricava per
ognuno si fà lo slideshow
però io così come se ne volevo mettere 3
mettendo anche questa così brillante
buio ma non so se quella che si illumina
al buio si vede mischiata con l'esa
colle chissà
lo scopriremo se riesce ad attivarlo
perché se non ti capita l'attivatore
dalla tiber hai mai
ecco qua le mie stelline gialle vediamo
come ci stanno nel mio primo amore
bellissimo e potenza colla non valgono
niente
la bellissima stelline gialle speriamo
che vi capiti la colla vediamo tu invece
che porta un altro
quindi siccome ho scelto più o meno gli
stessi colori dei glitter cominciamo con
una colla argento rimonta poi mettiamo
un po di questa qui viola
qui su questa il bollino e poi dobbiamo
mettere questa piccola rata
questa è quella giusta illumina al buio
non è proprio colorato insieme l'uno
recente sono proprio curioso di vedere
come diventerà tenersi alla finale io lo
so come diventerà ecco che a me spero
davvero che mi resta un 56
[Musica]
16 millesimi c'è una cosa che cosa devo
fare impresa per in fretta 14 14 paura
quasi trofino davvero sei lettere non ne
ho contate bene c'è scritto m
quindi la compagnia o un panino e al
personale col bellissimo che helbers e
la frolla earners e siamo fortunati che
quella diciamo vostro futuro noi ma sarò
a posto allora posso scegliere la palla
dei lettera altrimenti avrei dovuto
prendere nuovamente le perline
allora vediamo che scusate posso
scegliere bureau è con la n 1 non è
descritto come il mes
leggo questo selection pini ma scusa
perché non è che per di verde da un
futuro chissà magari anche di uscire a
casa il bello del suo prima dietro un
giorno giro e le ruote ma lo è dai 8
cosa c'è sotto l'inter e non ne ho idea
altri limite voi nei commenti se sapete
qualcosa che non può mettere per lo
slime e nel frattempo io dico interno ci
sono tutti ma forse sì non potevo vedere
da dove non ci sono ci sono ben tre
premi ci sono tempo tasca retta aiuto io
ti avevo davanti si sono proprio curioso
vediamo però la soluzione lenti lenti
[Musica]
soluzione denti abbreviato solventi
allenti soluzione se non doveva bene
perché voglio rilassa volenti o nolenti
nato non per un bar di queste brevi
esseri betta per la teca e mi dispiace
[Musica]
evviva via il vecchio un po di vantaggio
anche per me con l'aiuto di un'altra
cosa allora come scelgo per me non so se
copiarti e prendere anche la con
l'argento no così magari mette un galaxy
ma più bella del tuo uomo concreto
questo perché mi vuoi dare quello perché
così più facile magari con un altro
colore blu colore ancora più forte il
mio blu prima di aggiungerli però tocca
vitale girare ritroviamo questa volta
speriamo di essere un pochino più
sveglio 5 aiuto non un'altra cosa posso
vedere che cosa non lo so che posso
mettere nei piccoli hanno poi mettere
questo bene io lo so io lo so che hanno
fatto da una scollatura casellina te lo
dico che non ti puoi inventare nei colpi
dialetto leo prime azioni e 85 giusto sì
io ho scelto la mora sodio siccome il
bicarbonato di sodio e bene per questa
volta va bene così una parola inter e
non è abbreviate non è inventata noi la
soluzione per le cito potevo fare
attivatore no
[Musica]
ecco qua la mia bellissima col celeste e
poi la mia collaborerò però non
immischio già perché sapete che c'è già
la soluzione per lentini carbonato e se
io rischio già si attivano subito invece
voglio vedere cos'altro mi capita e
rischiare tutto dopo nel mondo l'ora di
vederlo st gol
si è così grossi alla fine i colori mi
piacciono tanto le cose bene
vediamo chi vincerà e questo galaxy e
ora con un po di bicarbonato di sodio
marcolongo al bicarbonato ma tanto ma
vedremo se ti capiterà la soluzione
altrimenti niente
11 11 prevista diete cosa dice lettere
[Musica]
altro suggerimento per dopo mi è venuto
in mente una cosa seria trombato ne ho
proprio bisogno però 11 lettere all'ora
di cena ci sia po di vento amici o
bicarbonato
[Musica]
anche se in realtà lo ha già perso però
magari non è abbastanza così per
attivarlo bene serve altro il
bicarbonato
[Musica]
so che a te speriamo con le minacce la
sosta 99 veramente niente ibra ti devi
sbrigarti ballare sei pronto
la flotta di posate ii iii secolo e
soluzioni soluzione ce l'hai fatta
ha fatto fortuna qui possiamo già
attivare i nostri slime si li possiamo
già attivare finalmente aveva mia non
sono proprio curioso di vedere come di
vendere una volta quei piatti mischiamo
vediamo un po di che colori diventerà
anche con queste stelline solo vivendo
oddio che strano non hai mai fatto uno
slam al contrario quindi sembra strano
silenzioso verificato allo slide rapido
e più rapido solidificato così però devo
un po l'avola le murelle un pochino devo
un po mescolando meglio con le mani
quindi ve lo farò vedere meglio dopo una
volta attivato bene comunque per ora mi
piace tantissimo se pronte rete nata
iomega il teruel
devo aggiungere la soluzione per lenti
funziona barletti aggiustare adesso
andiamo a mischiare avrebbero binello ma
no no guarda già un piccolo grazi
bene l'europa sia sotto rimasto
attaccato sono rimasti attaccati gli
iter che ho messo altre moto è vero
chissà chi vincerà il mio bellissimo
altro che il tuo nome ben che ora
finiamo di attivarli perbene slide bis
live perché il sito molto piccolo allora
il colore mi piace tantissimo e anche le
stelline sembra proprio un cielo
stellato
il problema è certo è che c'è qualcosa
che è andato storto durante
l'attivazione il fatto di aver messo
prima la soluzione per lenti e
bicarbonato della colla l'arreso con una
consistenza un po particolare e molto
solido vedete e in più si strappa che mi
dispiace un sacco perché vi aspetto così
bello stato attivato troppo allora c'è
qualcosa che non ha funzionato durante
l'attivazione aver lavato al contrario
non rovinato il peccato perché sarebbe
stato bellissimo guardate splendido
colore con le stelline glitter e
bellissimo
scrivete nei commenti se c'è un modo per
recuperarlo magari aggiungendo un po di
schiuma da barba un po di lezione
qualcosa sia costellato andata male però
vediamo ora quello di vitale come è
diventato grigio è un pochettino lilla 3
grigio e del grigio del menu esito una
sorta di calais è un galaxy stupendo
guardate poi la consistenza aggiunge a
quello di rito per york super glitterato
di un colori celestino grigio pallido e
celestino allora grigio di celestino v
giovani e quindi io dichiarerei la
vincita per vitale costa sovrani
stupendo e tu non li ha fatti solo
lirico quella cosiddetta che c'hai è
molto piccolo e ben casero il music
arena c'è il mio galaxy slime stupendo a
giocare
guardate i ragazzi molto piccolo
sondaggio se vinco io o se vince vitale
mi raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace
per vedere una terza silence del link e
ora vi lascio quattro casalinghe su cui
cliccare per vedere i nostri altri video
chat e su quella che preferite e buona
visione
ciao